And I think that the last three options could be valid responses.
I think the first one is actually not. And the reason for that are two things:
One is that I think it kind of does seem a bit suspicious but even if you don't think it's suspicious
you don't really understand what's going on here.
So on the last throws, it has all turned out very, very, very well.
So no 6 was thrown. Always 30% payout.
Now the reason could be pure chance and maybe the person offering the game at that point
just had bad luck but the thing is you don't really know.
So if you decide to play, I think you should only play a little
and it certainly depends on your risk affinity if you even want to get into the game
because I do think the whole thing seems a bit suspicious.